[موسيقى]
انا اتي لمنطقه الخليج منذ 25 عاما اتي
الى دبي وكل الامارات العربيه المتحده
للكويت وقطر والبحرين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه على مدار ربوع قرن وبفضل الدعم
الذي تلقيناه من هذه المنطقه من كل
الجنسيات بمن فيهم الاماراتيون والكويتيون
والسعوديون انشانا اقسام سرطان وعنايه
مركزه وانقذنا حياه عشرات الالاف من
الاطفال
[موسيقى]
فقط مؤخرا في رام الله انهينا بناء مركزي
عنايه مركزه مخصصا للاطفال بفضل تبرعا من
اسره كويتيه والعام الماضي بنينا ايضا
مركزا مماثلا مخصصا للرضع في مستشفى
الجنين بفضل اسره اماراتي وانا هنا من اجل
استمرار تدفق الدعم لان الحاجه في فلسطين
تتجاوز مواردنا ونحن نؤمن بان توحيد الناس
واظهار قيمه العمل الذي سيتم القيام به
وان حاجتنا تحتاج اليهم وهم سيتجاوبون
معنا وسيساعدنا
[موسيقى]
ما عنيته بذلك هو ان هناك الاف الاطفال في
الضفه الغربيه بل العشرات الالاف بل ربما
الملايين لهم حاجات مختلفه في نفس الوقت
يوجد في انحاء اخرى من العالم ثروات كبيره
وموارد عظيمه وفقا لخبرتنا فان الناس في
هذه المنطقه تحديدا يرغبون بالقيام بعمل
الخير لذلك ما نرغب به هو ربط الصله بين
اصحاب الخير ومن هم محتاجون له بنقل
الموارد من هذه المنطقه ومن امريكا
الشماليه لاننا منظمه امريكيه وترجمه ذلك
ضمن مبادرات وبرامج تنقذ حياه الاطفال
[موسيقى]